Wow
okay this is not a special effect you're
watching but genuine footage of a
shape-shifting octopus it was captured
by Massachusetts marine biologist Roger
Hanlon after hours of waiting on the
ocean floor as it's remarkable and
amazing as the octopus was I'm equally
impressed by the cameraman because here
he is he knew the thing was there when
it was very well camouflaged yes hats
off to Roger who was diving off Grand
Cayman Island when he came across this
jaw-dropping master of disguise but is
our eight-legged friend just chilling
off or is there a reason for this epic
demonstration they can disguise
themselves and sneak up on prey and also
larger fish in the ocean will eat
octopus 10 to the Dozen there so their
prey for an awful lot of other marine
organisms a survival of the fittest so
what is it about an octopuses skin that
makes him a king of camouflage the
octopus have just below the surface of
the skin a group of cells called
chromatophores these contain pigment and
they reflect light and they're attached
to tiny muscles which its brain can
control when it needs to it can control
those muscles and change color and
change shape which is the most
extraordinary thing about how it
camouflages so the skin just has an
infinite number of possibilities of the
ways that it can look but it's only
thanks to the patience of natural-born
thriller Roger that we actually get to
see what happens in an octopus's garden